[Music]
because if they say these are bad it's
not my fault no we got some real Beast
Burgers okay this is it Mr Beast that
old ass packaging oh oh God here we go
wait a minute
this is weird
that looks awful like a Big Mac
sauce
Special Sauce it looks like a Big Mac
dude
we order from McDonald's cheese lettuce
oh what is this it looks like two old
beat patties mustard sauce pickles
cheese lettuce
[Laughter]
yeah so this is a Big Mac then you guys
really yeah how are you gonna use my
card and not get an impossible Burger
you can eat beef why not oh I mean it's
impossible this is a beast Burger
yeah yes okay so these do look like Big
Mac so that is a big mac oh that is yeah
oh so that's what the Beast burger no
do you have like a team that we could
call like an HR son that's crazy because
we didn't do that you did no we did not
swear there's not a coincidence that the
ones without the stickers are Big Macs
and the ones with the stickers not
opened aren't
[Laughter]
yeah it looks like it's been centered
around a little bit but it looks good
I'm gonna take a bite right now it's not
my fault if it's been sitting out for an
hour
is there money in there
oh no I'm not gonna lie
I have fire it's got fries on it um
that's far hey that's Chandler so
whoever's on our marketing team make an
ad of him saying that and just run it
all over that's fine just Target
everyone within 100 mile radius of this
or anyone that goes to a show just hit
him with Instagram ads if I'm going
that's far
thanks I'd [ __ ] fire right yeah what
do you rate that one out of ten burger
burger review honestly
honestly now not honestly guys while
you're ready I mean honest with you
right now this needs a little more sauce
okay
probably because it's been sitting
around a little bit it's dried up oh
yeah this this the version they ordered
is the one with no sauce well you don't
need to throw it like that that's the
old factory they need to update it they
need to update that [ __ ] yeah agree
[ __ ] that package agreed what's wrong
with Angry Birds Packaging Patty yeah
excellent I agree Patty is excellent
dare I say the best you've ever had for
fast food okay dude I'm an in and out
Enthusiast I feel the return retention
you know just give us the rating so we
can love it
holy [ __ ] holy
holy that's a Mr Beast disc right there
reduction
step it up bro miles the single please
one out of ten
all right you know what I'll take it if
it saves the podcast
it's just hardwired you can't spend a
decade of your life studying how to go
violent how to get people to watch a
video and then have it fire a bomb in
front of your eyes to not like hurt your
soul yeah so you think about that with
everything yeah it'd be like the same as
if I started doing stand up there and it
was just god-awful you would be like I
gotta like what about during sex do you
ever be like oh
[Laughter]
yeah starting to look around the room a
little bit like Africa would be nice to
be back right now it's been more than
three minutes
I think we got enough RPMs
so is there a collab burger or food
product that we the flagrant beasts
products yeah I know hey
[Music]
besides your stupid Big Mac joke let's
go 10 out of 10. what's the problem dude
just look at his nose
I was trying to be a little subtle okay
I don't want to make Target
uncomfortable we're together now okay
was sitting there and then Dove moved
him out of the way it was really
interesting how strange that is a little
bit unfortunate
um